[Music]
welcome back to another episode of LED
live thanks for joining us today I am
here with Scott and Scott and this is
like Scott squared and it's not a me
versus them we're sounds like a law firm
I know Scott and Scott we should
actually start why not yeah so today
though what we are going to be talking
about is the coming crisis you take a
look at the around you and it's pretty
amazing when you read chapters in The
Bible like Matthew 24 it's like wait a
minute we're we're living that right now
and so it makes you wonder what else is
coming right there's other things that
the Bible talks about there's other
things that that the Bible alludes to
that tells us these things are going to
come to pass and Jesus tells us you know
when you see some of these things
they're only the beginning of birth
pains and some of the things we've saw
or scen so far we're like man if that's
the beginning what does this thing look
like when we get further down the line
so Scott I re I I understand you came
across this book and I'm fascinated by
this it has a title What's the title of
this thing it's 2025 2025 now you
listeners probably know we we did an
episode talking a little bit about 25
this is going to be different than that
um but that's a fascinating book because
it's it's talking about politics and
economics and
basically you would read that and think
were these guys reading the Bible when
they wrote this well when was this
written this was from the mid90s and
interestingly to piggyback on your
previous 2025 conversation you know what
the name of this futurist think tank in
DC who are well-funded they're big
corporate establishment NSA I mean these
are insiders at the global Elite their
group was called project 2025 that's so
weird in the mid90s so weird yeah and
they published this in 97 and it's like
here's all here are all the things that
we expect to happen in the world by 2025
and a lot of it is on this crisis level
conversation that you brought up yeah
when you look at Bible prophecy you
don't see the date 2025 and I I don't
want to be dogmatic about you know
something's got to be in 2025 but when
you look at the predictions they made
they were futurists right their their
their win rate is extraordinary I've got
a whole seminar where I'm going to not
only just teach on this but there are
other indicators pointing to 2025 and
the years that follow as crisis time and
so you know Matthew 24 is key and and
Jesus repeated it in Luke when you look
at Global crisis events people sometimes
have fear anxiety in fact Jesus said
men's Hearts will fail them for it will
it will but to us it means lift up your
heads for your Redemption draweth nigh
right so there's two different responses
perfect love drives out all fear that's
right so when we look at predictions
like this or Alice a Bailey the master
occultist or a lot of different
indicators historical Cycles we can talk
about any of all those but um the
seminar I'm preparing on it is called I
will not be moved so I thought about
just calling it The Coming crisis you
know but no focus on the security in
Christ anytime there's a crisis in the
Bible God has always given how to make
it through it exactly to do like he's
given the recipe he's not going to just
spring something onto the the end of the
world and like oh sorry good luck guys
yeah I mean it's like he's given us the
tools to make it what you find is the
enemy it's almost like he he shows his
cards like he lays them out on the table
and like this is this is what I plan to
do and that's why when we we take books
like this and we're like we recognize
like what we were talking about before
the show it's not prophecy no it's not
right this is not coming from God it's
not from an inspired Source exactly but
the enemy he can he can work and he can
plan and he can he can make things go to
a certain certain way but it doesn't it
it doesn't mean two things it doesn't
mean that it's going to happen in the
time that he wants it to happen because
God is Sovereign ex God on the and it
doesn't mean that it's always going to
work out the way he wants it to work out
going back to the same point because God
is Sovereign and and so we know that
things are going to happen because the
Bible says they are but it doesn't mean
that Satan's in control God's the one in
control and so we want to start this
thing with some encouragement because
all of this could be discouraging
especially if you don't know Jesus good
point yeah and by the way you're talking
about God is Sovereign aren't the Winds
of strife in Revelation 6 being held
back right now to give us time like when
when we look at the Historical Cycles
we're in we're in crisis time now and
it's only a matter of time before that
happens from Revelation 6 and the Winds
of strife come but he's holding them
back so that we receive the Seal of God
right so that we are prepared for the
coming crisis that's why all the
warnings are given in Prophecy so that
it doesn't come upon us as a thief
andless in darkness yeah we know what's
coming and and by the way all the time
prophecies in the Bible have been
fulfilled 1798 1844 way back to 27 ad 31
ad so 2025 is not a Time prophecy here
but the encouragement you asked it asked
for God is our refuge and strength I'm
reading from Psalm 46 a very present
help in trouble therefore we will not
fear even though the Earth be removed
even though the mountains be carried
into the midst of the sea though the
waters Roar and be troubled though the
mountains shake with its swelling there
is a river whose streams shall make glad
like peace like a river you know that
himym make glad the city of God this is
talking about the people of God the
Church of God the holy place of the
Tabernacle of the most high God is in
the midst of her
female always describing the church she
shall not be moved that's where I'm
getting the title from I will not be
moved God shall help her just at the
break of dawn God sh na the Nations
raged last verse the Nations raged the
kingdoms were moved that's what we're
talking about with crisis World War II
cyber pandemics but God uttered his
voice the Earth melted that's when Jesus
comes you know it's almost like someone
getting upset and trying to intimidate
you
if you know that there's nothing this
person can do to me or I'm in God's care
it's like they could make the the
elements go out of whack and it's like
you're still like nope sorry that that
even doesn't do it doesn't scare me
God's God's hand is able to preserve and
that's the amazing thing the the picture
this paints is the whole world is coming
down essentially around you and yet
God's hand is over his people amen and
it's it's like it's happening all around
but it's not harming them just like the
plagues that fell on Egypt right the
first three fell on everybody yeah the
last seven they touched Egypt they did
not touch the Israelites absolutely
absolutely you know interestingly in
that same chapter in Revelation about
the plagues you've also got the the
horsemen of the apocalypse and I as I
was studying that more deeply you hear
often The Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse and as if they're all in that
same category but when you when you look
at each one individually the first one
is white with a crown that's positive
apocalyptic imagery uh of not some you
know negative sort of ominous type of
event it it shows Victory it shows
Purity it shows royalty it's it shows
Christ he's he's Royal he is our King
but then it degrades down the second
third fourth Horsemen the second one
showing conflict and and and warfare the
third one showing famine he's got scales
and weighing out the grain but then
interestingly the fourth one contains
elements both of warfare and famine and
adds a third plague so it's like a
culmination of all crises at the end of
that I believe this has other symbolism
to it yeah but but bottom line when you
get down to the end you get uh a
culmination and and these feed on each
other throughout history War famine
plague War famine and plague one affects
the other when you have famine
scarce resources conflict over resources
War ensues in the context of war and in
the context of poverty sanitation drops
plague increases so these these tend to
do that throughout history but
especially in the last days Jesus says
watch out for pestilences watch out for
famines watch out for wars and rumors of
war in the last days and Daniel um talks
about it uh a very short summary in the
Book of Daniel 12 he says and there
shall be a time of trouble such as never
was since there was a Nation even to
that time and at that time your people
here's the promise shall be delivered
everyone who is found written in the
book so it becomes very important to us
to be figure out how do we get written
in the book right Right In Christ Alone
want to be written in the book yeah
because when you're written in the book
those things are are they don't have the
same power over you yeah they don't you
know people get scared of Alice a Bailey
because it's like it's the occult you
know she was this top un Acolyte and
founder of Lucifer's trust publishing
house so she's an open avowed luciferian
wrote the book The externalization of
the hierarchy capital T Capital H when
she writes that in her book and she
calls them the Masters again capital M
demon spirits and the externalization of
that Global power structure hierarchy
she says will begin in
2025 and wrote this nearly 100 years ago
yeah so what does that mean
externalization of the hierarchy well we
think of the hierarchy of the world as
like CL Schwab and Bill Gates and human
beings and they are just human beings
the prince of this world Satan is called
the prince of this world he he by fraud
he took Dominion of this planet he goes
up to the council with the sons of God
and God says to Satan where have you
come from this is in Job chapter 1 he
says walking back and forth on the earth
in other words like a lion pacing my
territory exactly and he said to Jesus
all these kingdoms have been given to me
and I can give them to whomsoever I
please if you will Bow Down and Worship
me so he's a prince of this world
there's a hierarchy of entities not
without God's sovereignty ruling over
this is the weeds and the wheat the
farmer says you got to let those weeds
grow under the Harvest and otherwise
you'll pull up the wheat with them when
they're small so in other words Satan's
principles are being developed so that
all Minds will say never going that
route again Rebellion against God that's
destructive but for the time being we
have a prince of this world running
around and that she says Alice a Bailey
says that this hierarchy these Masters
will openly unveil themselves and walk
on the physical plane visibly on this
Earth and and she's dating these this
period of the externalization of the
hierarchy where they reveal themselves
to and it doesn't have to be in 2025 it
begins then and I don't have any
assumptions about how many years we have
before the Lord returns so I want to be
ready now but know I don't want to be
too dogmatic about it's got to be 2025
but that's what's coming I think that's
why God cautions us to to not order our
faith after our eyes I mean even fire
comes down from heaven like that's not
that's not representative of that came
from God he's like look I've given you
all the information for you to study and
you should know this through and through
that your faith be built on this thing
here not what you see it's built on the
message not the miracle that's right
absolutely because people aren't going
to be able to believe they they're going
to believe that their eyes and they
won't they will disbelieve the word of
God oh yeah you start seeing demons out
in your real world experience I mean you
better bet that's going to shake some
people's faith and do you think they
will look demonic or Satan transforms
himself into an angel of Light
masquerades as an angel of Light and
here's an interesting thought you know
Roger monno the late Roger morno boy if
we could have him at this table we got
his old videos he he's done these
interviews and he's written his books
and he was an initiate into a satanic
secret society if you've got listeners
who are not aware of Roger morau and so
he spoke at length with the satanic high
priest high level about what the plans
of the enemy are and one of those things
he says the grandm plan at the end will
be that the demon spirits will appear
just like Alice Bailey said appear but
they will declare themselves to be
inhabitants of far Distant Worlds oh
yeah what's up with the alien Obsession
lately You' got hearings in Congress
you've got politicians you the Vatican
they're all aliens aliens why where did
this come from is is that going to be
the externalization where they walk
openly but masquerading as we and morno
says they will according to the satanic
high priest that he got this from and
then he became a Christian Broke Free
from it and did the tell all and he says
um they will come saying we're here to
tell you what to do so that you don't
bring destruction upon yourselves peace
and safety peace and safety and I think
Hollywood has done a disservice to the
whole world because they've put out this
idea out that an alien is
this so if it doesn't come as this like
nasty looking thing and all of a sudden
it's an angel of Light Well it can't be
an alien like what we've seen in
Hollywood that must be from God it's
like they've already primed everybody's
mind to just accept them if they're
beautiful y Satan is serving up allart
spiritualism you know he's got something
for every different kind of people group
for some people it's aliens for other
people it's different things you know
but he's ready to deceive the masses
with all kinds of different forms yep
yep and and in the context of that we're
here to protect you from destroying
yourselves it it's exactly not only what
the project 2025 folks were saying in
the 90s when they said World War III is
coming and they target 2025 but cut them
some slack they got a lot right I got to
tell you some things they got right but
but yeah it's in the I'm curious I'm
curious what they did get right this
stuff about the externalization of the
Hier is in the context of global
conflict and people look to Albert Pike
and the three world Wars and different
scenarios like that that have come from
the occult but they were making kind of
mundane predictions about society and
the economy and stuff but some of I've
got a whole list of 30 of them I won't I
won't bore you with every one of them
but some of them stood out to me as they
pinpointed the exact numbers like in the
90s GDP gross domestic product was
averaging 3.5% for the entirety of the
American Republic 4.5% per year in the
90s is what we were achieving and we
were seeing some good economic growth
and they said well 2025 we're going to
see 2% GDP growth now I'm kind of an
economics nerd I happen to know what GDP
is the last few years and since like
2006 it's been down to average of 2%
year after year after year just like
they said and then they said now you
really still sticking your neck out with
this one there will be a 120 m per
gallon vehicle that will go into into
service by 2025 Boom the Chevy bolt
comes out 119 miles per gallon and then
they say how why would you even think to
make this prediction it's almost like
are these predictions or are these
announcements but yeah it 40% of the
office-based workforce will be working
outside of the traditional office by
2025 that Happ Co happens and boom it's
41% 41% pinpointing it and then it's
thing after thing after thing that they
get right that aren't all numbers like
that but I wanted to share
those they've got some insight they're
not some fly on thewall Fly by Night you
know operation here these are big
futurist insiders top of the line and
they say what's coming is World War III
I think the Devil is a mimicker of God
right yes so he's watching God and he's
going okay God's got all these
prophecies and he says this stuff in the
Bible and all of a sudden the stuff
comes true and everybody jumps on the
bandwagon and and believes it so he's
just mimicking and creating things where
he's going if I can make this thing
happen and then talk about it before it
happens then people will trust when it
does happen that these guys have
something going on it's not a prophecy
it's announcing your plans yeah he's
forcing it so um Dan e Roy's
great-grandfather was a spiritualist my
great-grandfather was a dentist in
Kingston Ontario and he was the reviewer
of the psychic acts that would come
through town levitators precipitated
painters uh seers uh psychics all that
and he would like review them for the
local paper and uh so we had seanes in
the old farmhouse in the 20s 30s and 40s
50s before for my time and so it's kind
of like my family business I just grew
up with that uh reading all the journals
and reading about his his his work and
so it
kind this stuff you inherited all this I
I inherited the family business of uh he
was they mostly into mediumship trans
channeling and that they had per the
times their own Seance medium so that
was the thing at night this is the after
dinner entertainment they sit around the
Seance Circle and you know and and the
Seance medium would tell them things
like there's going to be an earthquake
in Chile in like two weeks
or 3 weeks or whatever and the event was
right the timing was off mhm but it
happened multiple things like that it's
like the spiritual realm is aware of
things that are going on and things that
are happening or like you say or
planning on things happening or maybe
they're making it happen right but God
is the ultimate decider on time right
yes but but you see the level of trust
that people start to put in that and
that's a scary thing because it's
substitutes the word of God which is
very dangerous yeah absolutely and and
you know I am confident in what God's
word has said about wars famines
pestilences I I don't need those guys
and they they've announced it because I
think when you look at our series
technocracy that we did at belt of
truth.
TV the the there's a session called
deprived by Design so when we're looking
at famines food and energy scarcity a
lot of that is engineered oh yeah
intentionally for agendas at the
globalist level and so these you know
the fourth Horsemen if you will these
these final crises type of events
they're they're foreshadowed in here
they said World War III Mass starvation
they talked also about epidemics and a
big epidemic and a
bioengineered um treatment for that
probably certain words you shouldn't use
on YouTube I guess anyway um there were
many predictions that they made that
were correct regarding that covid era
but then also here's one for you I mean
not just the crisis that that they said
that they are looking at coming in our
in our near future but um uh smart ID
cards will be rolled out we like okay
yeah that's not a surprise but listen to
this part Revelations 13 students smart
ID cards that contain your religious
identity yeah that's crazy this is a
secular book why does that need to be
attached to my ID card right it's it
yeah exactly no buy no sell mark of the
beast revelation
I get if I get pulled over by the police
they need to match you know my height my
weight my eye color and all that make
sure I'm the right person driving the
car right but why do you need to know
where I go to
church well you know when you go to k CL
Schwab and he's out there saying a cyber
pandemic is coming that will make
covid-19 look like a small disturbance
by comparison and that's a famous viral
you know statement clip of Cl Schwab
with the world economic forum and and
they ALS see by the way cyber cyber
attacks um that context of sort of grid
down starvation deprived by Design is
where you then provide the solution if
you if you do what we say says the
authorities then you can have your your
your uh your credits for your buying and
selling but let's look at your religious
identification on your smart ID see how
these all connect they also talk about
constant monitoring of all business
activities in 2025 time frame as well uh
but the Cyber pandemic you mentioned
Black Ops in a previous inter interview
that we did there was that video game
right Black Ops and then there was a
Black Ops 2 do you know who was the
chief uh consultant on the script for
that game probably the US military it
was a highlevel futurist contractor
within the National Security apparatus
and his name is Peter Singer not the
eugenicist Peter Singer not that guy
that you may know about but this Peter
Singer the Wall Street Journal called
him the premier futurist MH so Black Ops
uh uh series gets him as the as the
adviser on the script and what when is
it set it's set in 2025 and the object
of the game is to prevent a Cyber attack
so I'm seeing enough angles on the 2025
thing that it's not just one group one
Think Tank like there seems to be
preparations in place where I want to
sit up and take notice I don't know
which Black Ops it is but part of the
storyline has the um the mark of the
beast and stuff and there's like a whole
city that they're trying to get him out
like why would you even put that in that
kind of a video game like and it being
like about the end of the world scenario
you know what I mean this I I think
there's so much more to these these
entertainments than than than we think
right in the Simpsons you know you see
things foreshadowed in there is this
another example of that um but you know
oh go ahead Keith no I was just going to
say Mikey was show me another video game
the other day where it was basically um
US military going after religion just
extremists you know cult leaders and
things like that and of course you know
I get it you know cult leaders can be
dangerous Bioshock was it no I don't
think so but you know it's like
eventually it comes down to like well
who's defining who's dangerous
yeah you know even if you're peaceful
yeah because in the end if if you have a
group of people that that you know are
true followers of God they're reflecting
God's character what is God like God is
love right and and if you have the
fruits of the spirit you know you're
you're kind you're loving you're
peaceful you're you know all these
attributes
that how can you say they're dangerous
well you remember what the pope said he
said a fundamentalist which
fundamentalist just me means I believe
in creation six day creation I believe
Jesus literally raised from the dead the
Red Sea part I just believe in the Bible
so I'm a Christian he says
fundamentalists though they may not
strike anyone are violent even if they
take no violent act they are violent
because the mental structure of
fundamentalists is violence oh what so
yeah it's you just get to Define and
redefine whatever enemy of the day you
want to determine as being dangerous as
being you know domestic extremists or
whatever language they'll use it's just
the group that needs to be targeted and
it won't be reason behind it and this is
where the propaganda machine will plant
those ideas and then people don't know
where it's coming from cuz it was in a
video game it was in a movie it was in a
music video you know and like all of a
sudden it's like they're thinking these
people are evil well why why do you
think that is it because of all the
Expos exposing yourself to all these
other ideas that you had yeah wow you
guys heard of the fourth turning by Neil
how this is this is a little less
esoteric than um Alice Bailey and the
Black Ops but the fourth turning is just
a mainstream scholarly way of looking at
history and I had a degrees in history
and never in my undergrad or my Graduate
Studies in history never encountered
until recently the Cycles view of
History because we usually think of
history as being a line right a timeline
it's linear and and maybe um an
optimistic view is a line that kind of
progresses and the advancement of human
Freedom or Technologies you have the
enlightenments you get the Scientific
Revolution Century by Century in the
modern age at least you see you see
progress or or maybe you have a Biblical
worldview that the general Society is
trending downward
into the abyss of immorality and the
weeds growing unto the Harvest but also
the redeemed having an upward climb to
the measure and the St and the fullness
of Christ but either way it's lines but
really when you think about time and the
passage of time isn't it naturally
viewed as a cycle and I don't mean the
the Eastern view of everything is just
in ying and yang and you know a
Perpetual cycle but things do tend to
cycle like Seasons right Genesis 8:22
says that seed time and Harvest summer
and winter will not cease so and then
the the generational view of history in
the Bible is also present where it's not
dated by years but by the age of this
patriarch and he gave birth to his
firstborn son when he was this old and
then he died at this age so it's a
generational View and then you think
about your own life it's kind of divided
up into Seasons you know early childhood
or your childhood spring your young
adulthood summer your middle midlife a
age which I know and I'm I'm pausing at
this just I just gotta have a moment
here I know you got to have a moment
here Scott Winter's
coming because you know what they say
the demographers say midlife is is the
youngest president who was ever elected
43 I happened to turn 43 last year and
I'm like does this mean does this mean
what I think it means but no no fall is
beautiful it's my favorite season in
Michigan September is beautiful and
things can change color and be brilliant
bright there we go uh and then winter
season the senior years so it's kind of
a you know we start taking social
security in our early to mid 60s so you
know 20 or you know a childhood ends
legally completely at age 21 you get
full adulthood at 21 for all privileges
in society so four seasons of 20 or 20
in change years and then you actually
Society is made up of human beings
living human lifespan so maybe history
kind of patterns on these on these
Cycles too as well as going in lines not
introducing an Eastern philosophy here
but but you can imagine Loops like this
superimposed over the lines sure that's
my present philosophy of history in a
nutshell and the reason that I I had to
think through that is because I'm
looking at what Neil how is presenting
and the fourth turning is here in this
incredible book I mean I don't agree
with everything in it but it really
reveals Cycles in history and I'm
encountering that going okay think about
the years of America's biggest crisis
revolutionary war Civil War World War II
when did the British surrender to the
Americans in the Revolutionary War 178
81 when did the Civil War start
1861 and when did World War II start for
1941 are you noticing a pattern here
those are exactly 80 years apart and you
you you look also at um summer seasons
where you kind of have Awakenings in the
Great Awakening or The millerite
Awakening in the mid early to mid uh
1800s and basically you can look at the
last 600 years of history and you see
these things cycling over and over again
when you go back prior to the American
Revolution to Ang American history you
zoom out a little bit and you find every
82 105 years another giant war on Q on
schedule and America's three biggest
were in that winter season so you know I
we won't get timelines out and and try
to do a whole lecture on this but bottom
line is you're seeing Cycles through
history and what are we in right now as
of 2008 we are in the winter season of
History the crisis season typically the
second half of a crisis season is when
it gets the worst and you have giant War
so that's on the on the table just from
a historical perspective uh we know it's
wars and rumors of War are coming but we
can actually get a little closer a
little warmer to timelines when you look
at history and there were Roman
historians that observe their own
history after some time in in the Roman
Empire and they were noticing these same
Cycles going back thousands of years and
they would say you know we we expect
this kind of event is coming keep an eye
open for that and they got reputations
as prophets just by looking at history
wow do do you do you think that the
devil is basically just trying and
exhausting every opportunity God if it
was just like this I'd be right so God's
like Let It Go ahead try if it was just
like this if I just had the right
technology if I just had the right
whatever if the people were just like
this or they all believed this or I
forced them to have this and and it's
like at the end of the road every single
time God has proven right the devil's
proven wrong until God says like he says
I'm I'm going to lay you out before the
Kings they're going to see that your
ways Satan are literally destroying
Humanity yeah and the kingdoms of this
world that he is so often working
through are coming to nothing yeah so
the kingdom of God is that rock taken
without human hands that destroys the
statue at the feet I'm speaking of
Daniel 2 and it becomes a mountain that
fills the whole earth so it's only a
matter of time yeah they're going to
they're going to wax and Wayne and
they're going to flail about and Empire
are most dangerous when they're dying I
believe the American Empire is dying and
I don't say that with any relish I'm
about one of the most patriotic people
you'll find I love the Constitution I
used to teach about the founding fathers
but all of the cycle indicators and all
the trends of the decline and fall of an
Empire are what we are witnessing yeah
and we we see some similarities with
what happened in Rome right exactly I
mean you see some moral depravity that
came into the picture in in an
unprecedented way and it's like we're
getting to that state yeah and the thing
with Rome is it it it was more or less
an internal implosion it wasn't they
weren't conquered by you know another
Nation like themselves there was nobody
on the Block essentially that could pull
that off militarily or anything they
weren't conquered that way but they were
in a way they were kind of conquered by
the Greeks and idealism but then kind of
internally imploded and I see America
very much the same way it's like who's
going to you know who's going to take on
America like military China maybe you
know Russia but that's a little it's a
little shaky there right they're they're
busy dealing with some other things but
economically and and the whole bit like
there's nobody else really I mean we're
kind of stand alone in that respect and
I see us internally imploding I I think
that's why like Tik Tok you know
remember that came up in the in the news
um a while ago when Trump kept saying
like Tik tok's dangerous like don't play
with this kind of stuff and then it came
out that there was like you know some
some sort of Chinese connection there
where they were like trying to
demoralize the the the generation I
don't know I kind of believe that yeah
like you know Modern Warfare used to be
I come into your country with the
strongest guns and force you into
whatever now it's like they're realizing
if we just like rot them out from the
inside yeah they'll implode on
themselves KGB Playbook 25% of it is is
you know sewing seeds of Discord in
another country it's it's trying to
divide the population yeah and that's
why it was like a big deal when you know
they were looking at Trump and the
election in Cambridge analytica and then
finding all this data like well did the
Russians like mess with this thing and
you see how America is like so polarized
politically and they're like yeah maybe
that might have been you know some
Russian interference there dividing
people because they
realize divided we more likely to be
conquered yeah that's true and that's a
cycle in history is a collectivization
and polarization in a winter season
individualism Fades and gives way to
collectivism what tribe am I of what
team am I on what is my worldw and
ideology and I identify with that and I
don't critically self-analyze my own I
only attack the other and this could you
mentioned is there a peer is there a
equivalency of the United States
military power upon the world that could
scenario World War III you know actually
actually compete and what what could
happen is if if if the Cycles indicate
that we're looking at Giant War remember
the 1861 winter season in America it was
Civil War yeah and we look at all the
indicators of a Civil War and we've got
every one of them yeah there was a I was
watching a TED talk with a lady who she
was a contractor for the CIA and they
were looking at all this data as as the
CIA and then as data analytics they kind
of combined two things together and they
were saying well here's you know several
factors like 38 58 factors that we're
looking at for civil war and they
basically took all that and said well
only two of them are really good
indicators that a country is in Civil
War but you know who they couldn't ask
the question of they couldn't ask the
question of themselves because it's
illegal but her as a private citizen she
said
guess what we have those we have those
two data points yeah in this country
yeah well if you think about what what
do we have in common As Americans
anymore just think on the ideological
Spectrum you're you're typically you
know viewed two sides what do they have
in common anymore it used to be we all
kind of had mutual tolerance freedom of
speech some basic American values or
maybe you wouldn't like the word
American because that sounds like you're
in one of the teams free to believe what
you want now yeah that's out the window
yeah so there is no Common Ground so
that is immense polarization I I
literally can't find a common set of
values that the polarized sides still
share it's it's dangerous level
polarization and you mentioned the you
use the word demoralization and you were
talking about KGB are you guys familiar
with Yuri banov and his comments back in
the 80s and '90s about he had come been
a KGB Defector and he's like much of the
Russian propaganda effort actually was
targeting the United States to try to
demoralize yeah think about our
universities and media you guys
specialize in that what messaging is
coming through to the upcoming
generation are they being founded and
grounded upon principles that help to
have a unified and thriving harmonious
Society even a pluralistic society it's
not top- down on siiz fits all there are
many different expressions of of of
one's free choices and we know from the
Bible there's one way to the father and
that's through Jesus Christ alone but
never would we as Christians or should
any human being seek to coers mandate
pressure manipulate others into
believing even what we know to be the
truth God doesn't even do that right so
these principles of Freedom are just
history and it's you know you are
cancelled you are marginalized you you
you know if you don't tow the line then
then you don't participate in the
dialogue anymore one thing I saw
recently and I thought about doing a a
live on this but you know Trump and
again this is not to be like pick one
side or the other um but I saw him
selling Bibles recently and I was like
that's very interesting especially if
you kind of take a look at the Bible it
has an American flag on the front and
it's like in God we trust you know this
kind of stuff it contains the
Constitution the Declaration of
Independence the Bill of Rights the
words to God Bless America and it's like
and I was thinking I was like but this
is the Bible isn't it for all people and
all cultures in all languages and all
time like what are we saying to the rest
of the
world with that like that that we're the
only ones that are blessed or that we're
the only ones that can have Jesus or I
mean it's just it's such a polarizing
thing I think to do and it really kind
of borders on that church State you know
issue that that I think is like that
needs to be left alone God is for your
enemies not just for you I mean what if
there was a Bible that or all of a
sudden in China they were like this is
the Chinese China Bible you know what I
mean like of it yeah think of it like in
some other Nation doing that I America
would be like up in arms about that you
can't put your stamp on that but yeah we
can do it you know those those founding
documents in a way are sacred but they
are not uh anywhere close to being the
inspired word of God right so there the
god raised up this nation I I have high
regard appreciation for those docents
but yeah to put them in the and I know
it's not in the Bible like we're going
to insert it in the middle of you know
the gospels or something but it's too
it's too close it's too close for
comfort for me especially when they're
promoting and using this phrase let's
make America pray again yeah make make
now now hold on yeah make are you
serious kid I have not seen that oh yeah
you know he toggles back and forth
between acceptable language that I would
support and that kind of thing that I'm
going no no no no please stop please
he says we should protect Christianity
because it's under attack true and that
is the role of government to secure
these rights governments are instituted
First Amendment says we can exercise a
religion freely and anybody can so you
protect not just Christianity but all
religions so I like it when he says that
but then when he goes to we're going to
bring back our religion in this country
our religion we don't have a state
religion are you speaking as a president
there or just as you and your family's
religion and if so why are you giving
favor to that you're going to bring it
back through what policies The
Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment prohibits the government from
favoring a religion so yeah it's kind of
kind of yeah it's dicey yikes um in
January of this year there was um um
released in each one of the Publications
there was like a a like Fox CNN uh
Christianity Today all of them talking
about we need to get back to God like we
need to have this day where people are
coming back what are the chances that
all those Publications would be putting
something out in the same month that's
just strange to me and and I mean even
even in Catholicism they were putting
things out in in Catholic news and stuff
like that I mean it's just like you can
see them just setting this thing up well
to make the connection to the 2025 thing
your previous interview on Project 2025
about the the current project 2025 not
the one from 30 years ago is connecting
exactly with this conversation because
there's one page in that 900 page
document called mandate for leadership
where this um conservative ideologically
uh this group of of interest groups they
come and they say we want to make it so
that business owners who are open on
Sunday are penalized with having to pay
their employees time and a half for
being open on Sunday even if they have
no religious beliefs you know a secular
employer now has a Sunday observance
Mandate of sorts not not mandating an
observance but nudging uh penalizing
yeah you're going to if you don't close
you got to pay time and a half and so
it's trying to get get them to do what
the state would want them to do which
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion now I I'll
give them that they do say if you're a
7th Day Sabbath observant then this then
you would have to pay your employees
time and a half for being open on the
seventh day Sabbath so there's a little
bit of leeway given in there but the
secular employer doesn't observe any day
and you're making Sunday sacred in the
law to him when you know the Bible says
otherwise on that matter still the idea
that they're tying Financial
consequences to it is just stepping an
inching closer to the binos cell oh it
sure is it sure is yeah I did I did a
video on the project 25 I didn't even
know you were doing that we should
compare notes because yeah on our
YouTube I was like alert alert this is
not constitutional this is an
infringement into Rel religious freedom
and are we going to have Smart IDs with
people's religious identification and Do
You observe the right day that the state
has mandated I we know about mandates
now they will do crazy things under the
name I think it was this year Freedom if
not this year late last year there's
just a Supreme Court case where they
were hearing a postal worker and he was
complaining about having to work on
Sunday right be and you know do you
remember the reasoning why it was his
observation is that we are so
materialistic and so commercialized in
this country that Amazon since people
are can order packages and have them in
a couple days people are able to shop
all the time Amazon had so much business
for the US Postal Service essentially
they can't keep up without being open on
Sunday and so they were like having him
deliver packages on Sunday when he
wanted to go to church they weren't
making an accommodation for him and so
they took it all the way the Supreme
Court but it's interesting that you have
this piece now coming in about that like
well we can fix that you know we'll just
put economic incentive behind it and
we're not going to force you but you're
going to feel the pain it's interesting
there I I think I just did find a
commonality between the right and the
left when there when both sides are
promoting their version of pushing
Sunday observance in the laws um both of
them site excessive consumerism so maybe
that is something we all have in common
a concern about materialistic
consumerism um but they're utilizing
that common concern and I say the left
is as well because it's we're going to
have you know we have too much carbon
emissions too much industry and we need
climate lockdowns this is what you all
knowah Harari of the world economic
Forum said he said you know Co wasn't a
very deadly virus and look what we were
able to do lock down entire country shut
down all flights and this should give us
some idea of what can also be done about
climate change and then the UK Guardian
put out the case for climate lockdowns
and they're like carfree Sunday
so we're going to have industry
transportation we're going to reduce
human consumption and they pick a day of
the week to make that happen and it's
because of excessive consumerism and and
and the environmental uh perspective on
that so you know we're trying to
maintain neutrality biblically we are
not of this world our kingdom is not of
this world so you can look at both
objectively hopefully we can be
individuals and critique uh what you
might see as dangerous developments on
both sides so having said all of that
it's like you see all these things
coming you see all these things being
predicted you see all these things being
pushed and at the end of the day it's
like you could be real worried you could
be real anxious right but we open this
episode with hope I think that's go what
God wants for everybody is he wants to
give them hope no not just hope about
the end right and what's going to happen
but he wants to give you hope in your
present everyday living hope that you
can overcome hope that you can not be
addicted anymore hope that that you're
not a slave to something hope that there
is a better world a better tomorrow
that's what God is offering us on the
table so we can look at those things and
we could be like just you biting our
nails over them and like what am I going
to do we don't need to do that the God
of all peace the Prince of Peace has
given us hope so let's go back to that
yeah that opened with Psalm 46 well you
know there were people the martyrs the
reformers uh Peter Paul people who were
imprisoned and were to be executed the
next day and they're sleeping the sleep
of perfect trust they're singing hymns
in the in the dungeon and it's like you
can face like these guys are like
there's going to be a big nuclear event
and Martin Armstrong Cycles are looking
at 2025 as the beginning of World War
III and nuclear in 2027 but we can have
total peace about that peace above the
storm do not be anxious for anything be
anxious for nothing but in everything by
prayer and petition present your request
to God with Thanksgiving in your heart
so I'm thankful for life today I'm
thankful like these guys were they know
they're going to die the next day I mean
God intervenes of course and saves them
but could I be like okay a nuke's going
to go off you know soon and I'm okay
with that because of this right read it
again yeah God is our refuge and
strength a very present help and trouble
therefore we will not fear even though
the Earth be be removed and though the
mountains be carried into the midst of
the sea though its Waters Roar and be
troubled though the mountains shake with
its swelling there is a river whose
stream shall make glad the city of God
the holy place of the Tabernacle of the
most high God is in the midst of her
that's the key yeah our is our
relationship with Christ first last best
and everything in our life God is in the
midst of her she shall not be moved the
listener to this who's going this is is
intense listen to the word of God Satan
wants to induce fear perfect love drives
out all fear you shall not be moved amen
that's we can end with that Psalm 46
1-6 thank you all for joining us in this
conversation about crisis and what's
coming as Scott opened with we know that
all the prophecies in the Bible have
been fulfilled what is there left to
come there's Jesus left to come and we
can have hope and encouragement in that
and we do not have to be moved we do not
have to be discouraged so thank you
Scott for joining us thank you all for
joining us make sure you like this
episode give it a thumbs up make sure
you subscribe to this channel you can
help us by praying for us so we can put
out encouraging and bold messages like
this one you can also support us by
going to lightwear do shop and picking
up some merch like Scotty and I are
wearing t-shirts and hoodies those are
pretty neat things also you can donate
on patreon or go to our website LLS tv/
or/ donate and those will um those will
definitely help as well also remember
Scott ritma belt oftruth Ministries
check out his channel belt oftruth
dot belt oftruth dotv is y and then easy
to remember the YouTube channel is Scott
ritzo belt of Truth Scott ritzo belt of
Truth all right we'll have those links
in the description below and we will see
you next time on an episode of LED live
thank you for joining us take care
[Music]
[Applause]
o
[Music]